a minha história ela tem um começo como
foi dito eu não sei malacacheta não
confundam como macaxeira que a comida né
mas é fica no norte de minas e na minha
cidade geralmente pra pra gente
reconhecer uma pessoa
a gente pergunta pra ela e com família
que ela é
eu acho que acontece na maioria das
cidades do interior é alguém rio ali eu
acho que já foi perguntada dessa forma e
isso é mais do que perguntar quem é a
sua família é também uma espécie de
leitura da sua condição social e
econômica religiosa e até amorosa né
sabe tudo faz um check list a partir da
família de onde você vem e nunca
reconheciam quem era minha família né
é a partir do momento que eu falava da
outras referências nunca sabia quem era
minha família
esse reconhecimento ele só vinha depois
que informava o nome da família para a
qual a minha mãe trabalhava como
doméstica e foi a principal função dela
é desde que ela saiu da zona rural onde
ela trabalhava com o pai trabalhou com o
pai dela desde criança e em função disso
a minha mãe estudou até a quarta série
mas se tem uma coisa que ela sempre
priorizou e valorizou foi a nossa
educação e constantemente a gente ouve
ela dizer que a gente deveria estudar
para ser alguém na vida
era como se ela dissesse que a educação
era o único meio que a gente tinha pra
mudar a nossa vida
por mim eu também ouvi os professores
falarem que só conseguiria ser alguém
quem tivesse uma faculdade e uma
profissão
acrescentando a carreira como uma
condição a mais para se chegar a ser
alguém e também eu já tinha visto muitas
pessoas serem apontadas como um zé
ninguém
por falta de trabalho e também por falta
de de estudo e essa era era um exemplo
que eu não queria seguir sermos é quem e
como eu disse à minha cidade fica no
norte de minas e é quase um se irritam
né
o sertão de minas na verdade que é um
lugar onde falta todo tipo de recurso
recurso físico recurso material recurso
natural porque lá tem a falta da água
lá é o lugar do castigado pelo sol é um
lugar esquecido o o sertão né o sertão
mineiro o vale do jequitinhonha o vale
do mucuri e eu tendo crescido ali
naquela cidade
eu vivia constante sensação de estar
privada assim como a cidade vive essas
privações eu também tinha essa sensação
de estar privada de experimentar outras
coisas de ter novas oportunidades de
experimentar coisas novas e um exercício
constante que eu fazia e ainda faço
sempre que o retorno à minha casa que
continua no mesmo lugar no alto do morro
onde tem uma vista privilegiada para o
centro da cidade
então o exercício que eu fazia
constantemente era parar na porta da
minha casa e olhar olhar para aquele
horizonte olhar para aquelas montanhas
quem já teve a experiência de conhecer
vale sabe
e que é uma infinitude de de montes um
sobre o outro e nunca se acaba ea minha
experiência era essa de parar silenciar
e admirar aquele horizonte mas não era
um simples admirar era um admirar com
uma dúvida de me perguntar o que teria
além daquelas montanhas de me perguntar
o que existia além daqueles valores que
existe além do meu vale e essa dúvida
ela me perseguia
mas o que eu não sabia era que ela fazia
parte de um desejo de mudar
ela fazia parte de um desejo de me
libertar
libertar de algo que estava determinado
que eu seria aso eu permanecesse no
mesmo lugar
era um desejo genuíno de mudar o meu
caminho de fazer um caminho contrário
àquele que que muitos escolheram aquele
caminho que outros permaneceram por medo
comodismo ou até mesmo por submissão mas
era um caminho que eu não queria fazer
era um lugar que eu não queria ficar e
nessa construção toda de estar em um
lugar de ouvir professores dizerem de
ouvir a minha mãe falar eu já sabia o
que me levaria me tornar alguém eu
precisava entrar na faculdade
uma profissão e
ter um trabalho em ser o caminho que me
levaria ser alguém
só que a minha própria cidade não me
ofereceu esse recurso como eu disse
privada de todos os tipos de recurso
faculdade é um bem que lá não tinha e
dentre as minhas alternativas uma era
sair da minha própria cidade buscando
ser alguém como sempre disseram que com
o passar do tempo eu já tinha definido e
tomei uma decisão que eu deveria sair de
lá
então eu pensei nos meus planos e
resolveu sair de casa
resolvi desbravar aqueles horizontes
aqueles valores e arrisquei sozinha
sozinho eu descobri belo horizonte e
pensa eu saindo do interior e chegando
na capital em plena praça sete
gente tudo era muito grandioso
eu morava no vale né ea própria própria
a própria situação do lugar
a forma geográfica do lugar ela tim com
limites
é o vale eu tive o privilégio e tem o
privilégio de morar do alto da cidade
eu consigo ver lá embaixo e consigo ver
no alto e quando eu cheguei o belo
horizonte tudo era novo pra mim e veio
uma amiga logo depois que eu já estava
aqui que também era da minha cidade e
ela ficou tão tão extasiada com belo
horizonte que um dia a gente parada no
no ponto de ônibus na avenida amazonas
à noite ela olhou para o edifício
acaiaca e viu as estapas e falou dos a
lei que foi menina
o tamanho daquela casa de maribondo
a gente é do mato é a gente tem o
conhecimento da natureza
então imagina no alto do prédio uma
estátua é uma casa de marimbondo né
eu fui não sou louca é um estatuto que
está lá e durante o dia ela pôde
perceber que era um índio que tinha lá
né então pudera muito grandioso para a
gente tudo muito diferente e eu comecei
a me adaptar
nem a essas novidades de belo horizonte
mas aqui eu já vim pro belo horizonte
determinada a fazer minha faculdade
era o que eu queria só que pra eu pagar
minha faculdade pra eu sobreviver
eu aceitei trabalhar como doméstica
assim como minha mãe fez durante muito
tempo
trabalho só que eu aprendi desde criança
ea gente deve valorizar todas as
oportunidades que nos levam ao
conhecimento porque eu saber ele é o
único bem que nos pode ser retirado
e assim eu fiz na faculdade eu me
esforcei me dediquei passei madrugada
estudando
assim como muitos fazem e da mesma forma
eu passei a noite chorando mas lembrando
o motivo pelo qual eu havia saído de
casa
o motivo pelo qual eu havia saído de um
lugar tão longe
eu precisava ser alguém e o título da
faculdade ele iria me favorecer isso ele
me tornaria alguém e eu fiz exatamente
como disseram que deveria ser
entrei na faculdade conclui que tinha um
trabalho
só que as mesmas pessoas que sempre
cobraram eu deveria ser alguém
elas também surpreenderam porque elas
acreditaram que eu não poderia ser e eu
me tornei alguém e antes mesmo de sair
do curso eu já estava no trabalho novo e
foi uma grande mudança mudou
completamente a minha vida eu dei um
salto de vida e aí eu entendi o que a
minha mãe queria dizer eu deixei de ser
doméstica já estava trabalhando em uma
outra função que assim que eu terminar o
meu curso já elevaria a atuar com
famílias junto ao serviço social
e eu confesso que mudou totalmente a
minha vida essa condição mas esse meu
trabalho ele durou apenas três anos
porque no momento em que o país iniciava
a crise space tempo estabelecido até o
momento de hoje que a demissão em massa
era a única alternativa que as empresas
tinham para a contenção de gastos
eu fui demitida
eu passei a não fazer mais parte do
quadro de funcionários
mas passei a fazer parte da estatística
dos desocupados do país e eu percebi que
os títulos
eles já não me garantia um novo trabalho
ser qualificada inclusive até bem perdia
de ter uma nova profissão o que
geralmente acontece quando a gente tem
um tipo de graduação e quer procurar
outro serviço que não seja dentro da
nossa área
talvez a gente é colocado como
capacitado demais preocupar aquela
função
em razão disso a gente permanece sem
trabalho e aí eu volto a me lembrar
daqueles é ninguém
e embora eu tenha investido anos em
conhecimento
mas naquele momento pela falta de renda
pela falta de trabalho
eu me coloquei naquele lugar me sentir
nada e novamente
ironicamente no encontro da amazonas com
afonso pena
é meio a carros prédios gente era como
se eu pudesse conta que eu não era
ninguém
eu era ninguém e só mais uma seguia o
fluxo da multidão que vai num passo
acelerado sem saber pra onde vai porque
quando a gente segue o fluxo
a gente simplesmente seguem a gente é
conduzido a gente vai e se deixa levar
diante dessa nova realidade eu tinha que
fazer uma mudança de vida estava sem
trabalho estava sem renda e uma das
minhas alternativas era fazer um caminho
de retorno à minha própria história de
voltar no meu interior de encontrar a
minha essência os meus valores de
encontrar o meu querer de encontrar o
meu desejo e acima de tudo encontrar a
mim mesma
e foi assim pio na experiência como
doméstica o conhecimento da faculdade
a experiência que eu tinha com o
trabalho que eu exerci embora fosse
pouco tempo eu arrisquei em um negócio
próprio
eu criei um serviço para levar qualidade
de vida para as pessoas
é um trabalho que busca a mudança de
hábito em função da organização do
espaço das pessoas e também a
organização pessoal
se um dia a minha função na casa das
pessoas na casa de família era
simplesmente executar hoje
pelo meu conhecimento para casa e para
as famílias
eu ensino a melhor forma de executar o
que eu descobri é que ao empreender
eu faço o meu caminho o que me guia é o
meu coração eu tenho a liberdade para
ser protagonista e não vítima do
trabalho a partir do momento em que eu
empreende eu aprendi que eu não preciso
temer e eu não preciso ter medo não
preciso atender às necessidades e nem os
anseios da minha família
os anseios dos amigos e da própria
sociedade que estabelece determina o que
a gente deve ser
eu descobri que através do meu trabalho
eu posso mudar a vida das pessoas
isso é o que me realiza saber que eu
levo transformação na vida das pessoas e
acima de tudo eu trabalho me completa
eu descobri que eu não preciso ser
alguém muito menos 10 ninguém
eu preciso ser eu mesma
sabem por que foi percorrido do meu
caminho
três momentos eu vivi será alguém seja
ninguém e ser o mesmo e posso dizer que
aprendi pois estava determinado
não sei exatamente por quem que o dia na
vida eu deveria ser alguém mas no meio
do caminho
mesmo depois de ser alguém a deus
trabalho a deus dinheiro agora já não
sou ninguém
mas foi na história interna
naquela que ninguém leu eu busquei os
meus recursos e me disse quem seria eu
hoje já não mais determinam escolhi não
ser igual
quem determina sou eu a minha liberdade
de ser plural pegar
[Música]
[Aplausos]